what's going on guys it's October the
spookiest month of the year and that
means it's time for one thing universal
Halloween Horror Nights the screen
junkies team is here yeah we are gonna
go through some of the scariest movie
themed mazes you can imagine and I have
a question who do you thinks gonna be
the scariest scaredy-cat dead Dan meet
Dan thinks it's Dan definitely yeah it's
probably gonna be Dan are you guys ready
for this let's go
none of this stuff is going to be
scarier than the house I grew up in this
is not a good idea I don't want to do
this no fists no fists no punching oh oh
I thank you thank you I'm nice lady
many locals over there
hey you got me good
come on no no Andy go we'll just go oh
god that was like off-the-charts scary
I can we just go can we could you get
the render of these and just get this
done more than oh yeah all right let's
do another one yeah we are entering the
crimson peak maze have anything to do
with Crimson Tide no submarines involved
what's happening
throw in the bear there's a lady behind
okay okay okay that is not cool
oh I know where to go why don't we go in
the creepy now I don't know ma'am we
could have a bird call the police Terry
please there's somebody there's somebody
here I think I'm just a go oh my god
okay that one wasn't as bad that one was
not as bad I think the Halloween one was
worse is it weird to have an erection
yeah yes so outside the walking dead
experience about to go in there and I
would love it if the internet could make
a meme of us as the walking dead
characters maybe Andy as Rick if you
could do a nick as call and me as Daryl
and Dan as Carol horse as Carol so like
that
please make that happen Internet I don't
have I don't need a Spiker
these poorly placed spikes will keep you
at bay
happy feet Wow I'm looking for call yeah
call again no how you doing sweetie not
good I think Dan made a pee-pee in his
pants
oh yeah Go Daddy go this is the best
episode of The Walking Dead I'm sitting
this is like rocky when he's beaten the
meat is this a real
Oh
dan well I just need to apologize I'm
sorry I kept sacrificing you and said
take the virgin me into the maze Nick
yeah well look it was either me or you
and no it's gonna be you yeah no I want
to go home your season one Carol all
right we got warm up guys god damn it
this is the end we're about to go into
the 3d this is the end maze and they
gave us 3d glasses in 3d I'm a little
worried about this it's 3d you really
can't see anything happening yep
something's here
tree person tree person or whatever that
is I'm saying it's a tree person I don't
like it okay all right oh okay I don't
even know I don't even I think there was
just someone screaming I don't even
think that was a thing
where's Craig Robinson and Danny McBride
why don't we have this your face that's
right oh okay this is going to go off at
some point
oh I know I was gonna do that welcome to
hell mother oh you got me oh no we're in
hell oh no there's a guy thing they're
these guys I don't like them I don't
like them I don't I don't like that guy
Oh
no get out it there it's going it's all
good it's all good definitely gonna use
more devil other than that was pretty
good that was that was the worst one I
think really yeah no Halloween I think
the stuff I think we started with the
worst one but that was the second worse
for me Nick what do you think Halloween
the worst boy how I got how Halloween
definitely the scariest I agree
Andy ah yeah Halloween probably the
scariest you guys we have just barely
made it out with our lives from
Universal Hollywood Horror Nights final
thought I want to go home I did not
enjoy this I really enjoy what she can't
get scared he was really scared you got
a lot of pleasure out of that it was
very fun it was scary too but fun scary
yes tap it out yeah he had enough um I
was legitimately scared if you could go
through a scary maze dedicated to any
movie what movie would it be let us know
in the comments section below best
answer ah we're gonna send you a spooky
screen junkies t-shirt I gotta thank
Universal Hollywood Horror Nights I want
to thank my good pals for having my back
and scary times and I want to thank you
for watching hit us all up on Twitter
bye Mike one of the coolest things that
arrow does is it has so many comic book
Easter eggs
this season on arrow he used the boxing
glove arrow that is like a comic book
fan dream to see that in live-action